welcome back mother's day is tomorrow
and as local restrictions ease
more people will be out and about
celebrating the covet 19 has caused a
flower shortage
that's impacting some people's plans
madison kimbrough explains
yes sasha luckily it's not too late to
get flowers for your mom at miss daisy
flowers located off of west desert inn
road
but for many they would be surprised to
know that there is a flower shortage
going on right now
jessica marshall owner of miss daisy
flowers says business has been great now
that places are opening back up
and more people are coming to vegas but
even though she's getting a lot more
orders the number of flowers available
are just not what they used to be from
wedding bouquets to bridal showers to
birthdays and graduation bundles
the shop has been busy but the concern
is that there aren't enough flowers to
go around
covid really affected florals in the
industry
really worldwide because the farm
stopped
growing flowers last year it kind of had
a trickle effect
up until where we are today so with it
being mother's day tomorrow
and it being a very successful mother's
day it is harder to find product right
now
because prices are so high and there's
not as much availability
now fortunately marshall says she has
been able to keep up with 250 deliveries
being made just this weekend
so if you're interested in miss daisy's
arrangements you can go to their website
as they are still
accepting orders they also have candles
stationary
and bath and body sets you can
incorporate with the flower bouquet you
choose
and remember flowers are appropriate for
any occasion so it doesn't take a
holiday to bring a joyful bouquet to
someone special
reporting in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now